在我的生活中，我對這場比賽是最好的。
這場比賽是非常棒的。
我可能以為我可以做到35個比賽。
但我認為是更好做到55個比賽。
35是場地你試著贏的。
55是場地你開始贏。
來回家
哈囉，朋友們
我是瑞雪
我是一個喜歡全球旅行。
體驗文化和生活的多餘演者。
那剛剛你們聽到的是我和最近新出的電影。
奧德賽的主演
馬特達蒙的對話
我這兩天剛剛從北京回到上海。
是因為我去那邊參加了奧德賽。
在北京舉辦的首映裡。
那天我們在全國最好的IMACS。
畫幅上面看了這部電影。
並且當天導演Christopher Nolan。
他們的製片人Emma Thomas。
以及兩位主演 Matt Damon。
和Charliss Theron都有到達現場。
還舉辦了一場非常精彩的講座。
並且第二天還受到環球的邀請。
和馬特達蒙坐下來。
面對面的聊了聊
我看完電影的感受。
那如果有在小紅書上關注我的朋友。
應該有看到
我從去年開始
有開始經常採訪不同的電影主演。
那這一次
我的感覺非常的不一樣。
因為與其說是一個採訪。
我更覺得他是一個成長福的。
因為馬特達蒙真的是一個。
非常溫柔的人
他看人的眼神非常的真誠。
回答也總是能夠用幾句話。
非常精準的說到重點上。
並且這是我第一次被我的採訪者反問。
問我對我自己提出的問題。
是什麼樣的看法
所以採訪出來之後。
我整個人都覺得非常的輕鬆和充盈。
那麼在跟大家分享採訪片段之前。
我想先簡單介紹一下。
奧德塞的故事背景。
奧德塞奧德塞這個故事。
是西方文學史上最重要的史詩之一。
它是由古希臘式人和馬創作的。
一個神話故事
它的地位大家可以理解為是。
歐洲版的汽油劑
或者是風神堡
這個故事的主角叫做奧德塞奧德塞奧。
他是伊薩卡的國王。
同時也是西臘聯軍中最聰慧的將領之一。
他一直以足之多謀而著名的。
翻譯過來就是我們的朱葛亮。
當他們在打一場非常難的仗的時候。
他想出來了一個非常聰明的技巧。
叫做木馬技
通過他的木馬技
他們成功的攻陷了特洛伊城。
打了一場非常漂亮的勝仗。
打完這個仗
他們就當然說說準備回家了。
卻萬萬沒想到
他在回家的路上遇到了各種各樣的困難。
有被詛咒
有遇到了怪獸
有遇到海妖
還有各種各樣的天災人禍。
所以回家的這一路。
他走了整整20年。
奧德塞這個故事以及這部電影。
講的就是他打完聖上之後。
回家路上的種種經歷。
多的我當然就不跟大家繼續劇透了。
大家如果沒有看過這個故事的話。
我想想一定會被這部電影非常精彩的視覺。
以及這種接二連三的讓人意想不到的。
困難賢族所驚喜到。
那麼接下來我就想跟大家分享。
我和馬特達蒙的對話。
我們幾乎是完全沒有刪減的。
跟大家分享了我們的所聊的所有的話題。
那麼接下來就享受。
因為我們全都在做這部電影。
而且我們覺得這個機會。
我們是第一次 ever try to do。
一部電影就像這部電影。
你知道嗎
然後我們感覺到我們是搜尋者。
我們是第一次去
所以我們有很多的心情。
還有很多的尊敬
為了大家的努力
我認為這部電影是一種。
很 Romantic experience for sure。
還有很多的信心
對
因為我看到的 backstage of the making of the movie。
the huge machines。
all those armors that you brought to Iceland。
to such a place。
Can I ask which month was it?。
That was in June。
June's, okay。
It was there summertime。
but it did not feel like it。
I can imagine。
because Iceland is hard enough just to be there。
Yeah
It's a beautiful country。
I shot there with Chris on Interstellar。
we shot on the glacier。
and it's an incredible place to work。
and really good crews there。
and good people。
but very challenging。
And there was a moment where you were on the boat。
and a dolphin just jumped out from the sea。
and I feel like that's the magic。
Yeah, that's the magic of being out there。
things happen。
and you just are in the real world。
And I feel like you can always see that in a movie。
You can see it in the faces of everybody who's out there。
You know, that it's really the wind and salt water。
and all of that。
You're in the elements。
and that's what this movie needs, right?。
You need to take the audience。
and put them on the journey with the characters。
and that's what that IMAX format does so beautifully。
And you were in there too。
because you were exactly experiencing。
but the characters are experiencing。
Yeah, it makes it a lot easier to do my job。
Yes, I did when I was watching。
I was just thinking。
Man, just let this poor man go home。
All he wants to do is go home。
but there were so many challenges。
one after another。
and usually most stories tell us。
how difficult it is to win。
but Odyssey concentrates on what happens after the victory。
So I wonder why in this story。
Going home is harder than winning。
That's a great question。
And that's been the question since it was written。
What is the aftermath of the victory。
and what does it mean。
and what do you carry。
and to what degree are you accountable。
for the decisions you make。
What does that mean for your life?。
And what it takes to win。
What comes after。
If you don't take accountability。
for what you did just for winning。
That's right。
It's not just about a hero。
It's about everyone。
What are the sacrifices。
that you're willing to take。
That's exactly right。
Yeah, and in fact。
when I first read it。
I said to Chris that。
it reminded me in many ways of Oppenheimer。
and it has some similar themes。
and of course this。
the Odyssey is so rich thematically。
It almost depends on where you are in your life。
when you encounter the story。
because it can be about homecoming。
or family or love。
or war or death or regret。
There's so much in the story。
that depending on。
what you're going through in your life。
or how old you are even。
what your experience has been。
it speaks to you in different ways。
So what is your biggest take away from the story?。
I loved the adaptation that Chris did。
and I was the right。
at the right point in my life。
to take this role on。
it's an amazing role。
and you know。
I probably would have thought。
I could have done it。
when I was 35。
but I think it's better to do it at 55。
when you understand more。
Yeah
and also I kind of feel like。
35 is the stage where you try to win。
and 55 is the stage。
when you are starting to come home。
Yeah, yeah。
I think that's right。
I've definitely felt that shift。
coming into my fifties。
you get a new perspective。
a lot of life is behind you。
and you have a good chance。
to reflect on that。
and really think about。
where you're going。
where do you think you're trying。
to go right now?。
is it easier than odyssey?。
definitely easier than odyssey。
I think
you know I'm very lucky。
with the family that I have。
and the family that we've built。
I have a very clear sense。
of where home is for me。
Oh, that's so beautiful。
Yeah
So I really love。
love the line。
at the end of the movie。
which I actually saw before。
I watch it is。
what you most wanted。
is what you most can have。
and what you most can have。
is what you had but lost。
kind of scares me。
as a 30-year-old。
because I have to be careful。
about what I want。
Yeah
What's your intake about this?。
Well, I'm much more interested。
to hear yours。
That's why I love this。
this part of the process。
where we get to put the movie。
in front of。
in front of people。
and hear how that resonates。
Right?
Because I think it's a very。
personal question。
Right?
So it'll resonate。
with everybody differently。
but it's a very profound one。
it's a very profound idea。
Yes
and it's something。
you hear a lot of people。
later in their life。
as they're reflecting back。
and thinking about。
what they prioritized。
and what they didn't。
and regret。
can accompany that feeling。
for sure。
Because what I understand。
before watching this movie。
is I've been thinking about this。
recently a lot as well。
what I want so much。
desperately。
and work for it so desperately。
I actually have it already。
or I will have it eventually。
otherwise I wouldn't want it。
Right
if it's not writtenin my destiny。
or in my fate。
as it was said in the movie。
it wouldn't come to my mind。
because there are so many options。
if it comes to me。
it means I will have it。
so when I want something。
I shouldn't be so desperate。
of not having it。
because if it shows up。
it means it's already there。
Yeah that's right。
that's beautiful。
Yeah
Thank you。
but what do you think。
No I agree。
I agree
and that kind of desire。
is a form of suffering。
right
Yeah and so it's always good。
to ask yourself。
those kind of questions。
at whatever age you're at。
and think about the answers。
that are coming to you。
and yeah。
and at my age。
it's a lot in my life。
is settled。
it's funny that you say you're 30。
I remember when I turned 40。
this is so much nicer。
than turning 30。
Yeah
because I thought。
there are so many questions。
that have been answered。
you know I met my wife。
and I had my children。
and I had you know。
and I'm like。
there's so much more。
that feels。
like it's calmed down。
in my life。
and that's a wonderful feeling。
that tranquility。
you enjoy it。
Yeah
Yeah I think I will。
take your word。
like I will enjoy the sufferer。
also when the tranquility。
arrives I will enjoy it。
Yeah
you will have earned it。
Thank you so much。
Really nice to meet you。